[Applause]
i mean you have sting
on a song i know and now i'm not even
gonna lie to you
i'm not the biggest 80s music guy
obviously the police legendary sting
legendary
i mean as a kid my only sting memory was
when he came out and performed missing
you
with a puff daddy at the vmas but like
dog sting is one of them guys he's one
of the jedi's
yeah and he think and he feels that way
about me now so
how did that relationship feature happen
because no one's getting sting on
projects like
i know my manager played the song
for uh his manager and his manager
played my album for him
and uh he picked mama as the biggest
song
of 2020 and he's like i would love to be
a part of that so he wrote his verse cut
it send it back to me and then wrote me
and um
i just think like he did his research
you know he saw that um the new york
times like called me like the trap phil
collins because i do like
sing like phil collins kind of sometimes
on track beats but like
um he respected everything my grind he
heard my story
and uh cut it send it back i loved it
and we
just kept in touch and i haven't had a
chance to meet him because of
what's going on yeah because he's in
london but um
this has been the best response i've
ever had with any song
any music nothing but blue checks in my
dms of like
legendary artists writing me saying how
much they love and appreciate the album
and how much they love my song
lies and they love my song mama so much
and
you know kanye west probably you know
people heard kanye west loves don't kill
me
and mama and stuff like that and like
from like people that have like similar
people we have mutual friends and stuff
and like
like just like legendary people listen
listening to my project and and then
writing me and
it just feels like such a blessing
because i released it for me
in case i did die because 2020 is like
killing everyone
you never know so in case i did leave
earth i just wanted to
put out a project without someone
putting it out for me and adding a bunch
of features
that's fair